I think Chris Rock made a joke as I men  would [ __ ] in a box if it wasn't for  women you can without the motivation of  women men do not strive it's part of  their ego boost so without that do you  think a man's going to be risking it all  to build a really tall building for what  if he's got no woman to provide for I  mean don't give up  they'd probably be hunting in the woods  we're not arguing that like women like  men don't want women and women don't  help Society the point is that women  don't or men don't need women for  survival women need men for survival  that's the point and being able being a  single woman is a privilege and as a  thank you we [ __ ] on them that's the  whole point